shotgun there's only two of us you [ __ ]
ten years later that 70 shows Ashton
Kutcher and Danny Masterson are back
together on the ranch just two brothers
bonding one thing that's definitely
changed since that 70 show is that you
and Danny both have baby girls now you
know what's cool is like we both like
from that show to this show we're going
through like stages of life at the same
time it's just awesome to be able to
share that right like we you know we
come to work and you know his daughter's
a good like a couple months old with my
daughter so we'll talk about like you
know what's going on and but you know
what they're going through what we're
going through his parents it's just
great to have somebody to share with how
you're gonna force them to be friends
BFFs
I ran out to force them they just kick
it they cut me oh yeah yeah there there
are terrors in the hall we actually had
to like calm them down wind eggs were
bothering the set next door we bring
them there every week they they run up
and down sometimes they'll be like a
really dramatic scene being shot my
daughter made craft service screaming
you know I want that so it happens but
it's been really fun having why it's
gonna running around the set and I hope
that they get to grow up there for the
next ten years